-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
You're watching.
Thank you for watching our show.
Well, guys, tomorrow
is Thanksgiving.
That's right.
It's here.
Thanksgiving -- it's the day
that you forget about
all the fighting and division
in the world
and just focus on all
the fighting and division
in your family.
That's right. Since it's
the night before Thanksgiving,
lots of Americans are getting
their antibodies checked
to see if they can fight off
Aunt Rita's mystery casserole.
[ Laughter ]
I'm actually hosting
Thanksgiving.
My favorite part is guessing
which relative
is going to get the one chair
that's shorter
than all the others.
[ Laughter ]
"Can someone
please pass the...?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Of course, lots of people
will be making turkey,
while others will be
cooking a turducken.
You know what a turducken --
It's a coronary inside a stroke
inside a heart attack.
[ Laughter ]
I read that the night
before Thanksgiving
is one of the biggest
drinking nights of the year
because so many people
go to their home-town bars
to see old friends,
and I think the bars know this.
I mean, just take a look
at some of the signs
I saw they put outside.
This one says...
-Wow.
-That's not -- Look at this one.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, there's...
And finally, there's...
There you go. That's --
I want to say hi
to all my friends
at the exchange right now.
Hi.
Hey, did you guys see this?
Tom Brady said that Thanksgiving
is the one day of the year
where he says "screw it" and
eats just like everyone else.
Yeah, and apparently,
the meal really takes
a toll on Tom Brady.
Here he is before Thanksgiving.
And here he is
after Thanksgiving.
It's just...
You just got to be careful,
you know?
-A lot of inflammation.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
The CEO of Ocean Spray said
that due to a can shortage
from supply-chain issues,
people who want cranberry sauce
might have to use
fresh cranberries.
I'm pretty sure this is
the first supply-chain issue
where everyone thought, "Good."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Thanksgiving
isn't just about food.
It's all about posting pictures
of your food on social media.
But there's some important
things to know
about posting
your Thanksgiving plate.
So I wrote a tiny song about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ PSA, Thanksgiving food
doesn't photograph too good ♪
♪ It just looks like
a big old pile of beige ♪
♪ I'm sure your dinner
tasted great ♪
♪ But that tan rainbow
on your plate's ♪
♪ Not showing up on no one's
"For You" page ♪
♪ Mystery scoops
of brown and white ♪
♪ Gravy filmed by candlelight ♪
♪ Ain't the look
that home cooking deserves ♪
♪ Hashtag dinner,
hashtag snacky ♪
♪ All looks like
you served wet khakis ♪
♪ Bowls of soggy burlap
for dessert ♪
♪ So, PSA, Thanksgiving food
doesn't photograph too good ♪
♪ In worst-case scenarios
looks gross ♪
♪ Just take a picture
with your fam ♪
♪ Or your friends together,
not of ham ♪
♪ That's why your mom told you
to wear nice clothes ♪
[ Song ends ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Well, I --
I read that Russia is demanding
that, by next year,
large U.S. tech companies
like Facebook
opens up offices
in their country.
Yep.
Facebook inside Russia.
It's like a fake-news turducken.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. Soon, Putin will be like,
"Oh, no, the spying is coming
from inside the house!"
This is cool, though.
Disney just announced
that next year
they're introducing
their very own
"Hey Disney" voice assistant
at Disneyland.
Well, not to be outdone,
another amusement park
is rolling out
something similar.
Take a look at this.
-At Busch Gardens,
we're proud to introduce
our innovative
new voice assistant.
Get all the information you need
by simply saying things like,
"Hey, Busch Gardens,
what's the weather?"
-[ Beep ]
-How the hell should I know?
-"Hey, Busch Gardens,
what should I bring
to the park?"
-Two flasks and a vape pan.
[ Coughing ]
-And, "Hey, Busch Gardens,
what should I do next?"
-[ Beep ]
-Try not to [bleep] die.
-Busch Gardens.
Just like Disney.
If you drink enough.
-Hey. That's nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some movie news.
Today, "House of Gucci"
starring Lady Gaga
and Adam Driver
finally hit theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep.
Tickets to "House of Gucci"
are $18,
but if you go to Times Square,
you can find a knockoff for $10.
[ Laughter ]
"House of Bucci."
Get this. Actor Steve Burton
was fired from the soap opera
"General Hospital" 'cause
he refused to get vaccinated.
Yep, they kept showing him
evidence the vaccine was safe,
but he had amnesia.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, wh--
-Wow.
-It's all right.
When he found out he was fired,
Burton went up to the producer,
threw a drink in his face,
slapped him, and yelled,
"I'll always love you,"
then stormed out.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard
about a woman in Canada
who ordered a toy
for her granddaughter,
but it turned out
it wasn't very child-friendly.
Look at this.
-Ania Tanner wanted to buy
an educational toy
for her granddaughter
and found this dancing cactus
on Walmart's website.
When it arrived, she decided
to listen to the songs,
one in English,
Spanish, and Polish.
-It just happens
that I'm Polish.
And when I start listening to
the song and I heard the words,
it's about taking five grams
of cocaine and being alone.
[ Laughter ]
-Her granddaughter was like --
Her granddaughter was like,
"Yeah, I'm really disappointed
I won't get a Polish cactus
for Christmas."
Has this woman
ever heard of a toy store?
Target? Go to Target.
Can we see
that cactus toy again?
[ Laughter ]
I think we could have guessed
he was on cocaine.
Don't you think?
Finally, a truck carrying
$400,000 worth of Jack Daniel's
overturned on
a Tennessee highway,
spilled whiskey
all over the road.
After it happened,
officials didn't know
whether to clean it up
or tip over a truck
carrying Coca-Cola.